did you ever go on a nice honeymoon
whenever you were younger you mean on my
marriages yeah
um
the first time I got married to Jake's
dad
um
we went to the justice of the peace and
then we went to Target for our honeymoon
oh yeah we had 36 bucks we could spend
so we bought a garbage can
and a case of beer and I bought a pair
of white shoes
and then we went home and we were really
poor living in the mountains of Colorado
and all our friends had gifted us canned
canned goods for our wedding present and
so we just stayed with our friends like
smoking a ton of pot and singing a lot
of musicians and singing and playing
music and that was our honeymoon we
camped out in tents and that was a good
honeymoon that's cool that was real
happy dippy honeymoon and then second
who'd I marry oh Tom Arnold and uh that
was the honeymoon from hell oh my God I
should talk about that honey sweats a
lot
tell me about it [__] where's my
[__] cigs oh
that honeymoon I didn't even want to get
married as we were saying our vows I was
crying in the closet like oh my God how
do I get out of this but I don't want
him to see me crying because he's
sensitive he'd beat me up so I was like
faking like I was uh
and uh
so uh we got married and
and oh my God what a nightmare so uh
that was a [__] nightmare I haven't
even talked about it did y'all go on a
honeymoon though yes we went to Mexico
oh God huh yeah okay has always happened
with him
some Hotel down there that had private
swimming pools because I'm like I could
have a private swimming pool so I can
swim because I I'm not gonna let nobody
get a picture of me in my bathing suit
because I was really fat and so was he
so we got oh we got a hotel I had
Acapulco
yeah
is it fun if you're fat and you hug
somebody else that's fat as it all it
must be awesome
oh yeah there's a lot of cushion
oh man plus it's nice to have another
fat person who love you because you know
everyone's so mean to fat people and
here we were like two big fat people
telling each other that oh you look so
great and you know we we were
complimentary to each other for the most
part with some dark [__] going in we
beat the [__] out of each other
you know
which was fun but uh yeah I mean look at
first well yeah it's best especially
when I got somebody's got to get beaten
every now and then one I got to hit him
it was fun oh yeah but if he hit me back
it wasn't fun you know
but anyways
uh there was a lot of ugliness to it but
anyway so there we were down there and
uh I'm in the pool and
um I look up and it's ringed by
photographers all the way around our
room but the best part is we were in our
room we had to order room service and
the front desk called and he answered
the phone and they said this is the
front desk and
um
your neighbors are complaining that
you're eating too loud
okay we ordered about 700 Main dishes in
there we were just eating up a storm
planking dishes and oh yeah the
neighbors complained and he was on the
phone I remember him going eating too
loud yeah your neighbors can hear you
eating
Lambert went out in the pool and it was
ringed by uh paparazzis
so they always interfered and ruined
everything but
it was fun the eating a bunch and
swimming with no Paparazzi was really
fun honeymoon till they showed up and
then I found out he told them where we
were going to be
you know he just really
out of his own way maybe
yeah he couldn't get out of his own way
I hear he's out of his own way now I
hope that's true Tom we don't talk no
more but anyways
then my third husband
Ben his name is
I have a kid with him buck he's 27 he's
just like his dad
um yeah where'd we go on a honeymoon oh
we didn't go on a honeymoon because I
was pregnant we uh we uh
yeah we just stayed home I guess uh no I
guess I I never really except for that
Mexico one never did a real
real
anything you're supposed to do yeah
I'd love to go on a honeymoon with no
husband I'll tell you why that would be
a great deal just go by myself you know
buy myself a couple you know uh
bodyguards or what have your securities
do whatever the hell I want
pamper myself look at Art I did have a
three month vacation in I I saved up all
my money you know when I uh got a
divorce off Tom Arnold I did go to uh
Europe for three months by myself oh
that's nice it was so nice and I went
and looked at Art and traveled all over
ate everything I could get my hands on
that was like my own honeymoon yeah a
divorce celebration that was fun and you
lived in Hawaii for a long time which is
kind of like yeah 15 years I've lived
there yeah maybe 18 years now and I
still live there part-time there in in
Texas here
Hawaii's like a honeymoon every day oh
it's gorgeous I just got back from Maui
like last week I hate Maui yeah that's
where everybody goes yeah it's crowded
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one